back to the samsung stage at GameSpot's
coverage of e3 Wow it's been quite a day
we just had far cry 4 in the stage and
now it's another ubisoft game it's time
for Rainbow six the siege or siege there
is turret that in there Rainbow six
siege you know that you've got rid of
this no need for the there yes see cheat
alright well adding Andrew sorry it's
pleasure to have you on stage it's
literally just asked him if you've heard
Andy or Andrew and then choose the other
one that's the type of guy horrible
interviewer so we I think we've got the
air the demo you showed elf at the air
Sony sorry the Ubisoft press conference
to talk the other day so let's say I
think we'll check we'll take take a look
at that and if you could maybe talk us
through cuz I'm really keen to nobody is
them it's obviously very different from
the last Rainbow six game I play it or
anyone plays which we in Vegas - I'm
kinda keen to know is the board we're
looking at is that like the main
experience or is that like a multiplayer
part of the experience so we're here
showing the the multiplayer game of a
multiplayer mode of acoustic siege so
it's all its PvP v e5 player versus
player hostage rescue game-mode yeah and
it's all about this news asymmetrical
siege gameplay we've made between
attackers and defenders we'll be
following the role of the the role of
the attackers right here okay so you
sure that the guys are getting ready
here so everyone's just like logging in
right yeah so we're going back to the
first-person tactical shooter no more
third-person cover so we're going back
to the roots of the franchise so as you
see here you see that we're in the
observation phase the four players
so right now you follow me uh Viet
ackers so they're observing the map of
the house they spawn the drone here
we're gonna go and drone around the rest
of the bone as a drone then when your
attacker is that how you always start I
drew it in the house yeah right now we
right now the the attackers spawn a
drone they evaluate the map so you see
they see the defenders right now they're
fortifying right they're fortifying
there they know the oncoming assault the
attackers is coming so they're doing is
they're placing fortifications around
the objective which in this case is the
hostage
it reminds me of like you know in the
nasty zombies mode and Cola Judi when
you're like building up the barriers or
the windows that type of stuff their
points nice as defender you can interact
with and like yeah sure it up is that
they're building a stronghold so the big
guy the big giant middle great stuff
it's a wall reinforcement which prevents
that wall from coming down from a breach
charge and the barricades actually
reroute people reroute the attackers
throughout the map what you seeing here
is the planning phase my tactical map
so the planning phase is back in Rainbow
six siege so the attackers right now are
planning out they decided you know what
now let's go and helicopter drop to the
roof and begin to match that way get the
drop on the person you're playing online
then with four other guys four other
buddies and you want to try it how do
you decide where you go thanks is a
voting system or yeah it's a voting
system we're getting back to the main
pillars of the franchise it's all about
tactics team play and tension so we're
gonna go right back in right back with
those things which the tactical map is a
part of so you vote on what you want to
do with friends after you have evaluated
and communicated throughout the
observation phase I noticed we've got a
few different low dies here as well so
you get cheesier your temple aura as
well before each mission so we have
prototype classes we're pre alpha right
now so there's some prototype classes
here for the attackers you're seeing
that we're following the role of an
assaulter we have a preacher and we also
have a point man and right now buddy
you're gonna see our brand new
procedural destructions a system in
action our destruction engine the first
breach take the first guy out you'll see
a lot of walls start coming down we have
a brand new real blast destruction
engine that is the center of the
experience Rainbow six siege so you see
the wall coming down here oh it's good
about the the brand new destruction
engine is that its material base so when
JYP's blows up it reacts like JYP's when
you shoot uh so you place a breach
charge on our ships wall it explodes
like JYP's when you take a shotgun you
shoot a wooden floor wooden service if
it if splinters like just like wood
Yahoo sort of a firefight between rooms
here defender moving around rerouting
themselves so what made you guys decide
to go back to this more kind of classic
Rainbow six experience is it just
because a little whole lot of other
people are doing you know like cheers in
different ways tonight like more like
Vegas and you want to okay I won't meet
you go back to your roots Mason live in
a second you want to go back to the
roots when rebooted the reboot of the
title in January 2013 they really wanted
to go back to the roots of Rainbow six
so again the tactics team played tension
but also we did a reductive study on
what makes Rainbow six what's that
gameplay it's all about two opposing
forces one people of the attackers that
breach and the defenders that wait for
the oncoming breach of the attackers
right that's what we did we sweet we
based this entire gameplay around that's
asymmetric gameplay around that but at
the core we intro and we include a
destruction because counter-terrorist
units they're surgical with destruction
so on both sides attack and defense will
be able to use that to your
Vantage attackers you get the place
breached charges on walls make new
navigational opportunities you'll see a
guy breach a floor pretty soon actually
get the drop on some guys and you see
here actually creates a new line of
sight for the sniper on the outside take
this guy out the same thing can be done
with shotguns with defense defenders can
actually make a giant hole in the wall
and throw c4 get an attacker ambush them
that we had a lot of fun here a lot of
player creativity in our game plan so
could you also play this game against AI
or is this is this game only ever gonna
be player versus player we have here at
e3 we're showing off our multiplayer and
but uh we will we've announced that we
do have single-player and co-op but
we're kind of top-secret right now we're
kind of keeping it close to the chest
but we look forward to sharing more in
the future and even with like so this is
obviously as you say you're showing the
multiplayer here I mean is it possible
to play this exact mode but with like
with five friends against you know five
AI populating this house no right now
it's five to five all PvP l PvP right
yeah it's all PvP so they they actually
barricaded themselves in the bottom
floor the last three guys so we're gonna
go in these and a drone around see
what's going on every position the
hostage and you both see the instruction
system at work the attacker is actually
coming together using their tactics and
doing a double breach here again going
back to the going back to the roots
going back to uh we also have no respawn
here so when you when you die you stay
dead however you can still instead of
just watching the death cam you go back
and actually use observation tools so
the attackers can reuse their drone and
look through the drone and call out with
any new vocations and the defenders have
a security camera system they can
actually say hey man watch out they're
flanking you they're gonna go through
though we're gonna go through the wall
so you know like a ghost cannon where
you can kind of fool around is what is
you want it's more like there's actually
a reason for you to do that so as you
say security cameras or or respawning
again as a drone so you can still get a
he'll play that's good that's one of the
joys of difficulties with that like yeah
one life money player game was just good
the Eddie who accidentally gets killed
right at the offset like that first
terrorist guy you've got there a boring
way and you're like God I want to be in
the action be so so they can still be
involved at least in some part like
they're absolutely involved I mean that
that communication is absolutely key
especially when you die when you go in
you can you can communicate with people
and really be leveraged leverage your
your your viewpoint right you're always
relevant again being a you
teamwork tactics it's all part of the
new gameplay so what happens if I'm say
like someone in your team like C psycho
here suddenly he realized he's left the
cooker on me and he quits the game hi
this I was not gonna fight this kind of
experience right now we have a wait wait
we've run to the game flow where you see
right here so right now we we haven't
really stressed out too much for you
we're showing off we're pre-alpha yeah
so we haven't Lea tightened up our
matchmaking system they're keeping
things close to the cards for now
interesting things but uh right now
we're basically just showing off what
happens there's only you know seven
seconds till o'clock you've an epic
ending to the to the demo we haven't
like stressed out the punishment system
where people quit out or whatever we
want to maintain the core gameplay and
focus on that right now
fantastic fantastic so I mean what's so
when can we expect to find out more
about you know rainbows sake so you guys
gonna be you can bake Gamescom you're
gonna be showing off the horse to fedor
so we're not uh we came here right now
at the pre alpha build we wanted to
announce the game yes a Rainbow six is
back the Father tactical shooters has
returned with this brand new gameplay
and we're really said to be here at e3
the response has been really really good
we want to come back and show more but
right now we're focused on iterating and
making sure we're working more games
show more when we have we're have a lot
more to show but when it's ready
we don't actually share yet but stay
tuned we have a lot more stuff okay well
M that's actually about all we got time
for still angry thank you so much come
on stage thanks a lot man Rainbow six so
you know it's great to have the
franchise back I've been I've been kind
of missing it you know I don't think I
realized how much they missed it until I
saw the demo again so it's great and but
yeah do you guys we're gonna go back to
the show floor I think for a brief
moment but we will be back on stage with
the evil within in just a few minutes so
don't go anywhere